[Music]
thank you so much for coming up I've
been anticipating this conversation for
a very long time it's a pleasure to meet
you man your work is inspiring and it's
an honor to talk to you today
likewise thanks very much Mike I think a
good place to start is to kind of
establish the world of poaching and and
what's currently going on right now what
is this like explain this whole world of
poaching
I mean poaching is is illegally taking
something from nature that you're not
supposed to be taking that I mean that
comes in many different forms whether
it's removing plants or even rocks right
up to killing elephant and rhinoceros
either for the tusks in the case of the
elephant or the horn on the Rhino and
the bushmeat the skins you know
ultimately it's a way to exploit nature
and in nature exploit animals and that's
the part that appeals to me or in terms
of trying to stop it is the suffering
that is happening to those animals and
you know I've got a certain unique skill
set which is unfortunately required to
protect nature and that's where we're at
mm-hmm and in terms of the landscape in
Zimbabwe in the neighboring countries
you know break down the kind of
economics that is fueling this whole
industry well I mean poaching is is
often a function of greed and of poverty
of greed coming from places like the the
Far East where ivory and rhino horn are
two highly desired prizes basically and
what that results on the ground is
people that are either trying to make a
living or trying to get further and
further in front going out and taking
taking what they can from nature and
selling that and I mean it's another
it's another currency for organized
crime and often the victims other than
the animals animals themselves in
organized crime are other people that
are at the lowest levels who are there
to carry out the function of of killing
these animals
sure I mean there's poachers that are
simply just trying to survive and then
there's organized crime okay where the
profit margins are super high I mean the
the price for these tusks is insane well
I mean in the in the case of rhino horn
Iran Oh horn can go for up to thirty
five thousand US dollars a pound and
it's not uncommon for a rhino to have
twenty or thirty pound on its snout you
know these these animals I mean that
they should be locked in safes but
they're out there running around in the
bush and you know it takes a very
concerted effort to try and give them
every chance of survival and in the case
of poachers they're going to be right
once we're going to be right a hundred
percent of the time of course and the
demand for these tusks is driven by
places like China and Vietnam China
Vietnam Malaysia is that they hold
mystical health properties well with the
case of ivory ovaries used as carvings
trinkets creates status you know when
these tusks in fallen particularly the
bigger ones are turned into these
intricate pieces they carry a lot of
value and that's seen by certain
cultures as a form of investment and
beauty and art in the case of a rhino
horn
Ronnie Horner traditionally has been
used as part of traditional Chinese and
traditional Vietnamese medicine and
varying curing qualities that are
recognized in those cultures but
recently what we've seen is it's become
a status related good and that is it's
similar to having a Rolex watch
particularly in the way that business is
done in in these parts of the world
being able to present someone with a
piece of rhino horn or a trinket made
out of rhino horn it demonstrates wealth
and and and a certain level of capacity
mm-hmm so in 2009 when you embarked upon
you know this this journey that you've
been on what was this state of of these
animals particularly rhinoceros and
elephant in terms of how many were being
poached how decimated were the
populations becoming like you know how
close to extinction are they
like what are the statistics on this
when I first got to Isambard way in 2009
I arrived in African without having too
much knowledge of of conservation or any
of these populations what was really
going on I arrived that I simply to go
and do some anti poaching and we can get
into the reasons that I went there in
the first place
later in the interview but the year I
arrived in Zimbabwe and 2009 that the
previous year that lost 15% of its black
rhino population of black rhinos listed
as critically endangered as far back is
that the turn of the 20th century there
was a million black rhino that were that
were roaming African reliance and 2009
were down to 5,000 left Wow
you know so it gives you um gives you an
idea of Murano is it is an indicator
species of not only what we're doing to
nature but doing to our planet and
ourselves and seeing that downturn in in
those numbers it I mean to me it was it
was a war that presented itself that I
chose to go at and and try to fight well
let's work our way up to that let's go
all the way back to the beginning you
grow up outside Melbourne amen yeah well
I was born in born in Melbourne raised
in Sydney yeah dad ran pubs so and we
lived in pubs my first 10 years and my
life and a pub and the last 10 years
getting kicked out of them but uh I've
read one story where I don't know how
old you were you must've been a teenager
where some guy came at you with a pool
cue and you just stared him down and
chewed your your beer glass in front of
them is that like apocryphal or is that
did that happen yeah yeah yeah that's
how it's not much come back when you
don't swallow yeah yeah uh-huh
yeah I was a bit of a young hothead I
suppose I'll say you know interesting as
I sit here and look at your book on you
and your desk here by Ryan holiday ego
is the enemy well it certainly was my
enemy for a long time yeah so you grew
up as a young kid a little bit
entrepreneurial
freediving for for fishing lines and
then selling them back to the fishermen
yeah so I said back back moved back down
in Melbourne when I was about 10 years
old with my parents obviously and we
lived in a small fishing town called
Mornington it's not it's not a small
town anymore but it was was quite small
back then and the fishermen would go
fishing for calamari or squid over night
time and I had these little lures that
colorful little things itself 15 20
bucks in there in there in the shops but
I used to sell them for five and so I
had you know free diet free dive down
and collect these lures and come back up
and sell them to the fishermen and use
the money from that to start buying on
my own scuba diving gear and put myself
through training and of course this was
paying off so what do you do you go and
get a bunch of shopping trolleys and
throw them in the water and wrap them
with rope and that's you know conducive
to catching more and more fishing lures
so like a whole enterprise yeah so you
know I was only 14 15 when I'm doing
this and just falling in love with being
in the water you know if I wasn't in
water or or near it
you know I was you know I was lost and
natural progression for me was to try
and join the Navy and become a diver
right so it was sort of perfect training
to become a clearance diver yeah yeah
yeah I mean yeah the sea it was my
office for many years and I loved being
underwater and submersed and just having
a task to complete under there so what
led you to that decision to join the
military you know I mean yeah it just
seemed like it honestly - it would seem
like a cool thing to do adventure I
joined the military for adventure yeah
you don't seem like the kind of guy who
could sit still for too long but what
are you saying that was I'm like
twisting and jumping around
yeah based on everything you've done I
was little Johnny the little [ __ ] up the
back it was always like throwing things
and getting in trouble getting sent to
the principal's office yeah that was
that was how was that kid so if I
everyone out there that is listening
that had an idiot like me in your class
and stunted your education I'm very
sorry
so there's still a gap between joining
the military and becoming a real Navy
clearance diver right like it's sort of
the equivalent of Navy SEALs
so I actually join up as an electronics
technician because they wouldn't take
divers straight off the street so I
joined up and eventually was accepted to
go onto the the clearing where they
called the clearance diving acceptance
test that's our version of your buds
hell week and it's exactly what it was
sleep deprivation and being exposed to
the the the four great pillars of misery
to be hungry tired cold and wet yeah
you'd know all about about that nose you
know those elements but uh yeah man I
got through that and then went on to
went on to training to become a
clearance diver and then September 11
happened yeah
was this did this coincide do you know
Paul de Gelder yeah and I pull very deep
were you guys in it at the same time I
think I was just getting out or I'd gone
over to the army at that stage the
Special Operations when he was when he
was coming through I'm sure right but I
know Paul well he's a good mate of mine
he's afraid too I got a funny story
Paul if you want to hear that Joe was
out filming a documentary now for those
of you that that maybe weren't listening
when Paul Liddy's show here you know
Paul is a survivor of a shark attack and
he lost his arm and his leg but so we
were filming this documentary and Paul
was there and we're doing unarmed combat
training and Paul's bloody tough so I go
in there and I'm me against two Rangers
I get flattened in two seconds they got
me on the ground tapping out and now
Paul goes in now Paul wasn't willing to
tap out and so what happened is he's
essentially wrestling with these two
Rangers but while he's doing it his
prosthetic arm and leg came off and had
been thrown to the side and he was still
wrestling with these Rangers and I had
him on the back foot and just then a
game drive vehicle with all these
tourists came around the corner and saw
these two local Rangers this guy's
missing an arm and leg wrestling on the
ground had to run over sides it's all
cool it's cool cool you know
he's a tough guy he's tough night he's
bloody tough and he's a good guys you
could go to you know just hanging out
never be with it's interesting that that
both of you guys have now you know taken
a place in this in this movement in
different ways and have such a powerful
voice like this that life has brought
you full circle to kind of you know
coincide on different but you know
analogous missions yeah yeah and I he's
got a great voice for sharks and for the
ocean and and animals in general and I
think that's a really important thing
because our movement and the movement of
of having a better understanding and
appreciation and compassion for animals
it's a story that we got to hit from
multiple angles and that requires
multiple people and multiple stories and
all that freelancer voices yeah you know
alright so September 11th happens and
and why was that significant for you
personally I mean it changed the world
for a lot of people to a place it would
never be the same again for various
reasons but uh I mean for me it changed
the course of my life the Australian
government formed what they termed the
first and last resort for a terrorist
attack on home soil and that was the
tactical assault group a very small
niche unit made up of various Special
Operations units and and navy clearance
divers I went across into that unit as a
diver and I've been there for a couple
of days and was told I was going on to
become a sniper or two which takes you
on what takes you away from the water it
does my fish out of water literally so
that was it man I went and trained and
and then passed qualified and and went
online as a special operation sniper
when was that
2003 2004 yeah and then you get deployed
so I left them the Australian military I
went to work in the private sector and
during the Iraq war you never went to
Iraq under our official military
capacity well actually well I did I went
with private companies but were employed
by the US military on the US Marines
a division called seaport is a civilian
police assistance training team and then
with the US Army Corps of Engineers
project matrix rebuilding major
infrastructure across the country yeah
and a big part of that scene from what I
understand it was that you were training
the Iraqi police force and you know
basically trying to get you know the
Iraqi population on its own feet with
respect to self-defense yeah look that I
mean that was the role me personally I
mean I didn't join the military to serve
my country I did it for adventure or not
I definitely wasn't in Iraq trying to
and trying to make the situation better
I went there for money and that's that's
a God's honest truth it just so happened
that the stuff we were doing there was
aiming to be constructive however it
wasn't and you know I think one of the
biggest mistakes of the war other than
going there in the first place was
disbanding the Iraqi army and the Iraqi
police overnight and then trying to
replace it with just a whole different
you know whole different group of people
in a short space of time and we made so
many monumental mistakes that have
scarred that country yeah yeah I mean
having to train all these people in a
very short period of time to do a job
they're ill-equipped to do right I would
imagine that resulted in you know a lot
of people perish yeah yeah you know you
know I was project manager for the Iraq
special police charge training academy
in northern Baghdad and we had you know
we were tasked by Congress to try and
deploy battalion-sized groups and send
him back out there on the frontlines
groups that were drawn from a mixture of
sunni and shiite backgrounds and and
from anywhere in the country and we
formed the groups and we sent him out
after six weeks of training and they
either got killed they joined the
militia and fought back against us or
they deserted and there's no greater way
to demonstrate a failed theory than a
synagogue obviously
but but politically they wanted to see
the big numbers right i discerned these
people out because that looks good on a
you know in a newspaper article exactly
a man and you know as a sign tom the
insurgency was really standing up and
you know a lot of that was laid or
contributed by the the people that are
being put out of work the ones that were
trained and the ones that had access to
all the weapons and all the explosives
across the country what do people not
really grasp or understand about what
that experience was like over there I
think it affects some it affects people
in different ways you know and I said
the thing that probably and I struggled
with the my you know II didn't get time
to reflect until you're out of it often
and he trying to look back and piece
things together and figure out you know
what it was all about and what you were
doing there in the first place and the
other thing that affects me the most
affected me the most was just seeing
what happened to the Iraqi people and
their culture in their country and their
families and their children and you know
I made a very strong effort to learn
Arabic and learn the culture when I was
there and spend time with families
eating with them understanding them
communicating with him and you know when
you can't sit down at a table and and
and break bread with someone who hasn't
been directly affected you can't do that
anyway there everyone's been directly
affected whether it's a kid that was
blown up on the way to school whether
it's a mom that's missing an arm or a
leg a wife that can't see anymore so
it's everyone's got a story man and
every story's tragic Wow
so you deploy you did 12 different
deployments over how many years three
years so I mean his deployment was a
deployment anything from two weeks to
six months six months with the longest
two weeks the shortest just depending on
what the gig was or the mission yeah
right
I mean you kept going back money was
good though I bought my first house um
before the age of 21 and Wow by the time
I left Iraq I'd six houses so is that a
common thing with the guys in your trade
there's they start buying real estate
with a
possible income no I wouldn't so it's
common yeah I mean it's I mean the the
Great Australian dream is to own your
own house I suppose but uh you know for
me I didn't want a house to live in I
just wanted residential property to
invest it and you know make money and
that that's what that's what that was
what drove me and my 20s adventure and
money and trying to make as much of it
as possible it was a status thing to be
honest so after that 12th deployment was
there something inside of you that said
like I'm done like I've got to find
something else to do I was starting to
get complacent you know we're going out
running up to four missions a day and
just complacent you know and that wasn't
fair on the people around me you know I
had enough money had enough houses that
you know I first smart with my money I
wouldn't have to work again foreseeable
future it turns out I did after I spent
it all on setting this thing up yeah but
uh yes about nine years of military and
you know I suppose I was just don't out
man I mean he's sitting there he like a
coiled spring for three years over there
and you know saying [ __ ] they and I get
up draw your weapons roll on missions
yeah and then come back in and [ __ ]
sit there and watch a television show in
your Surrey store yeah yeah I mean it
has to be super weird and disorienting I
had a a woman in in here to do the
podcasts the other day who suffered you
know terrible PTSD from from her
deployment you know to the point of you
know coming close to suicide and having
lost a bunch of people you know that she
was close with and it was interesting to
hear you know her journey back towards
trying to become whole again after that
experience I mean do you qualify as
somebody who experienced PTSD or do you
just think you needed to find like a you
know a healthy outlet for all that
adventurous energy that you have
I suppose the danger with PTSD is is
thinking you don't have it or saying it
doesn't affect you I think there's no
way you can you can go to a place like
that and not be affected in some way and
also you know it doesn't affect you
straightaway for a lot of people
right simmers below the surface and then
rears up often with a combination of
other factors in your life but um no I
mean if a car door slams or anna has
allowed unexpected bang on right now
yeah I'm the roof man but uh you know I
get a little bit of anxiety and stuff
like that but I suppose that's that's
what you get when you roll around
expecting to get blown up at any stage
for for any extended period of time you
you carry that with you but for me I
think you know for a lot of for a lot of
people that leave war the hard part is
leaving purpose and when you go and I
hate to say war its purpose but it's not
necessarily the war it's the unit's
you're working with and the people that
are you side-by-side with and these are
my case they're brothers and there's
very few other jobs where you spend all
working week together and then you want
to hang out or we can only guys it's
just it really is home robbery that
behind my nothing else it's it's really
hard to find them when you're not there
anymore and that all the skills I mean
you mean Special Operations it's it's a
special job you know and then when
you're not special anymore
you just [ __ ] someone else and that's
that's a lot to deal with for some
people and what your body's doing now
[ __ ] I mean there's a bunch of it under
killed themselves the bunch they've gone
on have been very successful in the
military in the private sector great
father's some now some people that are
really struggling here you know you know
he had a bunch of guys go off and and
follow the diving Sylar stuff in a deep
sea or as saturation diving but yeah for
a lot of guys it's tough I know and
women as well of course so you go to
South America first to basically like
party I mean what was the idea yeah man
I read a book called marching powder and
I said the best cocaine in the world was
made inside san pedro prison in La Paz
Bolivia now check it out how'd that go
yeah it tasted like [ __ ] but it smelled
good uh-huh look um yeah look not a year
I'm proud of but I suppose we all got to
look
on certain parts of a law I think it's I
mean I'm asking you not from a pure in
interest but really because I think it's
important like I'm always super
interested in you know how people take
their pain and turn it around and I
think in order to really kind of
understand that like I want to
understand like what you were endured
and what you went through and like where
it took you because at some point there
was a powerful catalyst that's that you
want a whole new trajectory yeah yeah I
mean a South Africa South America for me
was about him bottoming out and hitting
rock bottom and I don't know if that was
a self-destruct mechanism that I felt I
had to I had to hit to realize you know
am I gonna go all the way through the
floor or am I gonna use that to bounce
back off and come back up the other side
and fortunately you know it was the
latter can't back out the other side but
how long were you down there 11 months
in South America me a man just just
partying the whole time no no it was my
way of just tapping out and just I don't
know you know you tell yourself some
funny things when you when you think if
you've been working hard and you deserve
a break or you deserve things that may
not be good for you yeah yeah your mind
can play some really good tricks trust
me yeah yeah yeah I know yeah so did you
get are you sober then do you are you
like totally off everything or without
my still now I still have a beer and
have a drink love a beer and a drink and
all that but um you know let's just sell
consumer my share when I was over there
right of drugs and alcohol it was um you
know it was it was a dark time and you
know a bit a bit of played a role in
shaping who I am and where I am today
you know being able to look back and
reflect on our vulnerabilities and use
them as a tool for change I think is
what can make us truly human and nature
nature gets to evolve over millions of
years and we only have one lifetime to
do it so we got to [ __ ] get it right
and get it right quick yeah yeah well
that issue of vulnerability I think is
super important you know I mean you're a
guy who I look at and say you're
changing people's ideas of of
masculinity in a positive way in the
sense that you know we traditionally
align you know for whatever reason
dietary preference is with what
means to be a man and the willingness to
be vulnerable is seen as a weakness and
you know I've come to learn and
experience directly and through many
other people that I know that when you
have it actually takes a lot of courage
to be vulnerable under this and that's
what is the connective tissue between
you and humanity in your community and I
think it holds a lot of power to be
transformative for other people that you
know are struggling in their various
ways yeah yeah yeah you're right how you
know it's easy to bottle things up and
not talk about them and you know puff
the shoulder puff the chest out and and
you're trained to do that yeah I mean
well it's expected yeah there's a
difference between being trained to be
like that or being expected to be like
that and I think being expected to be
like that is harder what I don't explain
the difference and I like it me
interview if you're trying to be some
tough guy but then everyone thinks
you're a tough guy I mean a lot of the
guys we work with a special operation
are special operations now isn't just a
bunch of big 250 pound guys covered in
tattoos you know there's there's all
different shapes and sizes and you know
it's the small quiet going to make corny
got to be scared off not a big loud
mouth with the tattoos yeah I heard
they're happy so you know and for me I
suppose the hard part was is you know I
was a hard footballer and you know I was
a tough scrapper as a kid and it almost
like I felt as though I was always
having to do something to prove who I
was and to prove the next thing and
impress someone and that I suppose has
been one of my biggest downfall yeah
where does that come from you think
that's an Ironman just as a kid just
trying to find your place in the world
in the in out there and and figure out
who you are and where you're from and I
suppose you know you can get on a
slippery slope pretty quickly and yeah I
mean I did some cool stuff but uh I
wouldn't say I was happy with the person
that I was mm-hmm so how do you get from
South America to Africa one way to get
are you judo straight from there what's
that you go straight on now I went home
had a bit 11 months worth it dirty
laundry to take back to mom and and
I'll wait hive and just put some white
back on and I've got the end of 89 kilos
so what do you go with setting pounds I
don't know I'm sure someone is probably
like 200 pounds or something right
you're like what like 240 250 250 uh-huh
so dare just went back home 8 spent some
time with the family I've been away for
a better part of three years and I'm
very close with the family and
everything so I went back there
regrouped and offer went man had a
one-way ticket
why Africa ago I read a lot of Wilbur
Smith as a kid honestly it was another
adventure and I heard about
anti-poaching some years earlier
actually I just got a message about from
a mate yesterday he said I remember you
talking about that in 2003 mmm and in a
bar and I'd heard years earlier as well
so it's just interesting they just it
just sounded like a cool thing you know
and it's but was it that was it just
African Tommy did you have an intention
of seeking out this whole anti-poaching
thing yeah I mean I was I was going over
I was going over another adventure
another another another you know chapter
and Demi Amanda's lawful wasn't going to
do anything constructive was looking for
a call a fortnight of course and yeah it
was a another you know I would say it
was a misdirected use of more energy and
skills at the time and well looking back
not so much your intention maybe yeah
you know things have worked out things
have worked out really well and I
suppose I'm really happy with where
we're going as an organization I'm happy
with my own personal evolution and and
just I suppose and I'm proud to say the
courage that I feel I've had to stand up
for those that can't speak for
themselves
and to try and be a role model
particularly to younger men and you know
we don't we don't have to hurt things to
be cool you don't have to put people
down to be cool you don't have to be a
sniper to be cool you don't have to eat
meat to to prove how macho you are you
can just be you and you can be much more
powerful and courageous
and and much more of a role model when
you do what you believe in it's
interesting that you're you know you
said your evolution but that evolution
you know it's continuing to unfold like
the changes that you've made just since
you did that TED talk yeah are pretty
amazing right it's not it's now extended
to caring for all of these women and
it's almost become a female empowerment
movement as much as it is an animal
protectionist conservation movement yeah
interesting you say that you know when
at the core we're a conservation
organization not necessarily a female
empowerment organization we have chosen
to employ women and put them out there
on the frontlines and what is the only
Nature Reserve in the entire world
that's completely managed and protected
by women and we're doing this not
because we felt a pressure to equal
their numbers not because of me to move
what we're doing it because it makes
business sense and I think for a lot of
people that's important to understand
because it it makes business sense and
the bottom line is what influences a lot
of people I come from the ultimate boys
club special-operations you can be the
president of a country and be a woman
that you can't be special-operations and
so for me to be in a position now where
I am and and genuinely believe that
women will change the face of
conservation forever he's a big
turnaround and ego was the thing that
was holding us back the whole time
mm-hmm
well let's work our way towards that you
you arrived in Africa and and what you
just like immerse yourself in the
anti-poaching community I mean how does
that work
I tried to sell myself as you know this
tool that could be used and deployed out
there on the front lines and then you
start like here comes another white guys
yeah exactly a man and you know got a
lot of a lot of closed doors like people
and I get an email every day from
someone that wants to come over there
with their own sniper rifle or whatever
it might be and run around the bush and
hunt poachers and it's not like that
there's a far more complex situation
going on on the ground and this is not
the Wild West where you can just turn up
with your own rifle and go out start
hunting people you can join the army if
you want to do that but you can't come
to Africa and do that
and you know the position I've carved in
the industry and in Africa has been out
of granite it's been tough
a long hard slog and one in which I
invested a hundred percent of my life
savings to set up this organization and
and make a go of it and you know it
wasn't until I died I'd spent the better
part of six months traveling around the
continent trying to get a feel of things
that I realized you know maybe I'm I'm
going about things that right the wrong
way right and we um we eventually got a
start in in Zimbabwe and I just started
working with an anti-poaching unit and
just seeing the difference that a bit of
face time with these guys made you know
seeing now for them to learn that they
were appreciated and that someone wanted
to train them and work with them and you
know this was only in one area so I mean
obviously there's great efforts going on
across across many other areas but I was
just seeing impact that I was able to
make and then you also see you know I
just come from Iraq come from from the
military units I was in we're [ __ ]
made if I wanted anything I'll go to the
storeroom and get it if we need a budget
increase we get it you know we just
asked for it and I was part of a
military unit that was spending seven
hundred billion dollars a year it's the
annual defense budget and I was just an
instrument of war and you know you're
part of this huge funds you know
spending mechanism which is you know
we're looking after [ __ ] oil in the
ground and dotted lines on a map and
then you come over to Africa and you see
these people that protecting the heart
and lungs of the planet you start to
think [ __ ] you know what was I doing and
not only that I was trying to have an
adventure on the back of their hard work
so it made me feel um it may be really
reflect on who I was and what I was
about and I was increasingly becoming
the person that I didn't want to be
mm-hmm but there's this one experience
that you have like a moment where
everything seems like it from what I
understand it seems like it changed
things for you like coming upon an
animal that had been basically the you
know murdered and the tusks removed
and that was kind of a turning point for
you I mean there was those gradual
things that were going on but this
catalyst moments that the first one
being seeing a buffalo look at you know
one of the biggest and most powerful
animals in the bush there and one of the
most dangerous and she had a back leg
corner y snare and the Rangers can read
the ground like you read the front page
of the newspaper they they it's a
language to them and they were able to
determine that she'd been struggling for
three days and she ripped their pelvis
in half
China was scape you know these these
wise snares they're like landmines they
stay there and designed to trap animals
that walk through around the hay lays
the neck the head whatever it might be
and indiscriminate and you know animal
doesn't you know it's confusing when you
trapped in a bit of why you don't have
hands that won't do it or anyone to help
you and you know we had to euthanize her
we had to put a gun to her head and pull
the trigger
I should go birth to a stillborn calf
and that's some you know I may appear to
be a tough guy but something like that
will break your heart right yeah
and the thought was if there's a way to
bring to bear this skill set that you
have and you know kind of
institutionalize it it could provide a
line of defense against essentially what
is what you're combating which is you
know a highly organized well-funded
operation to poach these animals yeah
and up until that point the line of
defense was not organized not
well-funded people that lacked you know
certainly like the skill set that you
have to deal with this problem okay
there's a lot of good efforts that are
taking place out there but not enough of
them and there's a huge imbalance in in
this world in terms of what we're
willing to give towards protecting
nature and animals I think about 5% of
all charitable giving that goes out is
dedicated for animals domestic and and
wild and only 5% and and and the
environment religion gets about 30
percent and the rest is all humanitarian
stuff so there's it you know we want to
look after ourselves we
we got to look after nature to be able
to do that most effectively and look I
saw a problem I had two things a certain
skill set and I had money so I decided
to do something about it simple as that
there was no long-term thinking about it
and I was enrolled to can't be trained
as a chef down at Silverwood in Cape
Town at the time and you know that was
gonna be my next next life choice and
then once you know I'd got submersed
enough in in this with with the Rangers
that was it sell up and and start up so
you sold all your properties to like
self fund this thing yeah I didn't pay
myself a salary for the first three
years and just used the rest of the
money to to pump back in vehicles and
aircraft and training centers for
Rangers supporting various programs and
then got to a point where we had two
thousand dollars left in the bank
I thought she don't need to figure out
how to fundraise yeah and on a plane
come to LA yeah well TED Talks yeah yeah
that'll help but time this is now this
is many years ago we'd you know started
the organization it was sort of ragtag
small operation and who are you
recruiting to be your feet on the ground
where people in the community or some of
your peers from Special Forces like what
dude it's combination of the two and we
were working largely to empower
indigenous forces and ones that were
already in in a role not necessarily
going in to train new new forces and
yeah I mean a lot of the skills that
they need out there on the front lines
are very similar to what we needed in
the military and we don't need SEAL Team
six out there on the ground protecting
these animals we just need people that
we can trust people that are willing to
work hard that I'm well motivated and
well legend and with the right basic
equipment and I always say what we're
doing the first 90% is is just working
with people and you know we can't
replace people with algorithm is in
Africa the most important asset and the
value most valuable asset is that people
there and if you work with them and just
focus on the first 90% of you of your
model is is getting them well motivated
well lead well equipped then that'll
generally solve most problems the last
10% you can start introducing the sexy
stuff
the drones yeah everyone wants to talk
about the drones but you're always
bringing it back to the people yeah well
you know well the I mean there's there's
been a number of trials done with drones
in Africa and in conservation and
Concord I mean the bottom line is
conservation doesn't have the budgets
that the military does and so we sit
there stuffing around with with bits of
equipment that the military superseded
decades ago and trying to make that work
when in actual fact there's a reason the
military is has evolved and that's
because they've evolved to things that
work in in in tougher theaters we don't
have that we don't have those budgets
are there certain areas where everybody
knows these are the established front
lines where where the poachers tend to
you know navigate towards like how do
you know where the hot spots are where
the poachers are going to be like how
does all that work yeah definitely you
know one at one of the programs we ran
was on the eastern side of Kruger
national parks border on the Mozambique
side of the border and that is
essentially the piece of land that
separates a third of the world's
rhinoceros from most of the world's run
out merging syndicates and that is very
much the front lines there and you know
we the border was essentially the the
front line of the war there and because
they wander off the protected land and
then they're fair game for that or well
when they wander across the border into
Mozambique where South African forces
could not cross the border and then
pursue that myself
they knew that they could sneak up to
the border shoot across or cross over
shoot and then get straight back across
to Mozambique and we stopped that we we
created a viable force on the Mozambique
side of the border that was able to
pursue Mozambique ins on Mozambique and
tough what is the law like are you
legally allowed to shoot poachers like
shoot to kill if you catch them in the
act and how does that work I mean it's
very much the same as a Western law
enforcement models where you can shoot
to protect life as a last resort when we
teach our Rangers to use the minimum
amount of force required to get the job
done and
and what we're essentially trying to do
is not only preserve wildlife but also
preserve human life and you know I mean
you've heard something on Facebook and
you know you get all the comments
there's like I'll just shoot them and
stack them up and all that and it's not
about that you know you know we want we
have to work within the laws of the
countries that we're in and we actually
want to want to see this thing go to go
to trial and have a fair hearing and you
know we can't be seen you know we're not
some sort of vigilante force out there
we're working with the government
departments we we have respectable
people that are on our boards of
directors Jane Goodall as a patron you
know we we can't jeopardize that because
we want to go out there running around
and just hunting poachers it's not like
that on the ground yes so ha I mean are
you able to ward off violent
altercations in most cases or how often
does it escalate with the men I would
say you know and when I was when I was
in the military you know men you sort of
you get up to fight and always in that
sort of fighting mode encountering
surgeons or counterinsurgency is
countering insurgents you go and you
look for look for a fight women women
have proven to be very different in what
we've seen on the front lines and the 76
arrests that the the women of urkesh
inga have made in the past 14 15 months
have been made without a single shot
being fired which is quite remarkable to
see because usually there would be
confrontation there so so much
altercation the the area they're
protecting and I don't want to get too
far ahead here but the area they're
protecting is home to the second largest
elephant population left on earth 8,000
elephants are being killed in that area
in the last 16 years
so that's thousands of times teams of
armed men have come into that area
thousands of times that they're not only
willing to shoot elephants but the
people that protect them and for the
women to be able to operate in such a
dangerous environment and do so in such
a passive ways there's a lot to be
learnt from that now how are they doing
that like what's the secret there is it
empathy is it that the poachers are
reluctant to kill the women or escalate
its evac'd level of violence a women are
very good at collecting information
women form that the informal
communications networks of rural
communities
about three percent of crimes that are
solved around the world are solved by
catching someone in the act the other 97
percent that are solved is solved
through intelligence and intelligence
led operations and that requires
information to analyze turning to
intelligence and we can go out and do
those missions and the way that the
women communicate and not only
communicate but relate to the people in
the communities they come from gives us
so much information we know what's going
on anywhere at any one time when we have
to know it and a lot of the arrests they
do is based on the information they
collect and we go to the poachers house
at 2 or 3 o'clock in the morning
surround the place and it's it's over
very quickly the arrests that they've
made in the bush they're very well
trained very fit they're tough they're
well-armed we don't like the fact that
Rangers have to be armed and they need
these sort of skills but that's the
reality of it out there on the
frontlines and interesting and I don't
know the exact dynamics we're working
with the Chinoy University of Technology
to look at a number of different things
on this project that we we want to
understand from a scientific standpoint
because there's some really different
things that are going on here
I mean another thing for example the the
old patrol reports of when the men
worked in this area they were charged by
dangerous animals like elephant and
Buffalo quite regularly the women
haven't been charged once here and we
look at that we thought what's going on
then we found a study where voices from
two different trials were played two
elephants in Kenya and one of the one of
the tribes had historically hunted
elephants one had not the elephants
became very agitated to the voice
recording of the tribe that had hunted
them and not agitated to the other voice
recordings these animals know what's
going on man they're smart and we spoke
to the professor Victor and Posse at at
the the cut' university there I said
what do you think this is prof well it's
probably as simple as this what's been
hunting animals for thousands of years
it's been men not women and so if we can
scientifically prove that all female
patrols are actually much safer from the
biggest threat that Rangers face out
there not necessarily poachers but the
animals they're trying to protect you
know it's another dynamic to what we're
doing
that's super fascinating yeah I mean
that being being met with that specific
dialogue
and having them be agitated even if they
even if they weren't directly hadn't
directly experienced that before it's
almost like baked into the yeah genetic
code yeah yeah
that's amazing yeah I need to get back
to you on that man and let you know
where we are like I'd like to know it
statistic they figure out fascinating
and you know we're learning a lot just
but yeah I remember during the training
and there very early in the stages when
I'd never worked with women all that
units were all male and and I'm just
watching them and they'd been given a
team-building task and I was getting
super frustrated that they you know
there wasn't all the grunting and
groaning that you would expect with
doing what we were putting putting them
through at the time and and you know as
a bear to go and intervene and just say
you know look if you don't want to be
here then just you know I can pack your
bags and leave okay we only want people
that are putting in a hundred percent
effort all the time and then I shut up a
bit bit bit my tongue and went shut up
and sat down I just watched him and they
got the job done and they got it done in
time and they got done as well as it had
to be done they're just as far less
[ __ ] and I realize there's just
different ways of doing things well we
should just establish that you started
this unit called a cachinga which is
this all-female Ranger program what was
it like within a year right or a year
ago very recent August 2017 we started
higher and explained to me the impetus
to forming this I mean reading more and
more literature about the empowerment of
women and industries that are that are
transitioning to have more women
inclusive in management positions board
positions field positions and the flow
on benefits that they're realizing and
being part of a largely male-dominated
industry and particularly at ground
level where men outnumber women by up to
one hundred to one on the front Alliance
and the ratios you'll hear and different
there's a study done such 19 percent of
ranges are actually female but those
females are restricted generally to
looking after a gate or an office job or
not frontline jobs and so we thought
if women aren't being given access to
every every role at ground level then
they can't really rise into management
positions and be expected to make
life-and-death decisions in an
operational environment they can't do
that without having the accept that all
that experience behind them and I
thought well if we can't progress as an
industry an industry that's had tens of
billions of dollars invested into it and
we're still talking about animals going
extinct and maybe we need to relook at
how we're doing things I read an article
I believers that The New York Times
about the US Army Rangers and they'll
putting a platoon through that had a
certain percentage of women on there now
I have a close affiliation with the US
Army Rangers because we got into a spot
of bother in northern Baghdad and and
those guys came and got us out of this I
thought well if these guys saved my ass
in northern Baghdad and and they're
actually transitioning and including
women on in front
frontline roles now as Rangers in the
army then maybe we need Rangers wildlife
rangers that are females in Africa and I
mean this certainly women that are
employed out there and in various roles
but other well we looked at other
projects they were including women it
seemed almost like a token gesture like
women were being put in certain
positions but not even given the
opportunity to complete all the roles so
we thought stuff it you know let's let's
do a selection and see where it goes and
we tried and tried and tried in many
different areas and we got we got
blocked from this concept of having an
all-female anti-poaching unit an armed
one which there was no armed all-female
in deep ocean unit anywhere on the
continent there are other female
anti-poaching units but they're unarmed
with a block of black mamba the black
mambas is one example where they are
working outside and in in the
communities and doing a fantastic job
and building those relationships but the
inside of the reserve is is the role is
done by an armed male the unit that's
it's a private security company so also
doing a you know fantastic job but it
undermines the men because they're not
given the recognition that the women are
getting and it undermines the women
because they're not given the
opportunity that
are given to do every role so we you
know we wanted to create something where
there was complete opportunity for
everyone that that passed the selection
and when you say you were blocked I mean
what exactly was going ah there's
politically correct responses to why and
it wasn't the right time to look at this
or no thank you and no we don't want to
take the risk but you know we were
determined to give it a try and we
eventually found an area in the lower
Zambezi ecosystem in in Zimbabwe and one
of the largest elephant populations left
on earth an area that has been home to a
lot of trophy hunting operations
throughout the years and 20% of
Zimbabwe's landmass is actually set
aside for trophy hunting or Toto Safari
areas collectively are across Africa an
area the size of Texas is satisfied for
trophy hunting now if I was to say to
you rich mate we're gonna we're gonna
scrap 700,000 square kilometers were an
area the size of Texas we're going to
wipe out all of those national parks
across Africa people would be an
absolute uproar now this is happening
with all the areas that have been set
aside for trophy hunting but they're not
national parks they're communal areas
communal hunting areas they are areas
and have equal biodiversity importance
this national parks but let's just say
not not ideal for tourism is it are they
privately owned or is it government land
usually government or owned by the
communities okay excuse me here cups
owned by the communities and so when
these area when these areas do well the
communities do well and when they don't
they communities see no need to conserve
them anymore and they they move in the
trees get cut down the animals get
poached it often gets converted into
grazing area for cattle and so we we saw
trophy hunting not as an argument to be
had but rather as an equation to be
solved and we went on to this area to
try and create an alternative economic
model to trophy hunting at the same time
is trying to stand up this all-female
antipodean yes so it serves it serves
multiple agendas because one of the
things with
the International anti-poaching
Foundation and what you were doing
initially and traditionally is effective
but also sort of a band-aid on this
massive problem because until you get
until you create the right incentives
the right economics incentives and and
you're you're sort of woven into the
fabric of the community where they're
supporting what you're doing yeah you're
gonna be challenged right so by creating
this this all-female you know cadre of
women of Rangers you're basically
connecting with the communities in a
more in-depth way I think creating
incentives that these people can support
themselves and find a way you know a
better way I think I mean to summarize I
think women have become the bridge that
conservation had to build into the
communities and break down those
barriers and I mean historically when we
were forming an anti-poaching unit or
working with one the men that we would
employ would be employed from places far
away we'd bring them in and that's so
they they weren't living next to all the
working next door to their cousins or
the brothers and they you know they can
its give information of where certain
herds of animals are going to be because
I've worked with some of the best units
in Africa and corruption always creeps
in and I often say go in Africa I'm
getting upset with with corruptions like
you know the beach and getting pissed
off with the sand it's there it's how we
how we manage it that determines the
difference between success and father of
a program and if you can walk in and
take corruption out of the equation you
already halfway home and you know so
with the women we haven't seen
corruption yet we were 15 months into it
we haven't seen an incident of
corruption and that allows us to employ
100% from the local community right next
door to where where where we live are
working and that turns the biggest line
out and we have in conservation which is
law enforcement into a direct community
investment and putting money that would
otherwise be dispersed around the
country directly into the local
community at household level right into
the hands of women and just politically
I mean that makes it a lot easier for
you to get
doing what you're trying to get done and
then these women are empowered and they
can buy land and you know raise their
kids it's amazing watching uh you know
the transformation and each one of these
women has a has a tough story a tough
background they're all survivors of
abuse
you know domestic violence sexual sexual
violence AIDS orphans single mothers
abandoned wife so they've you know when
we put them through training we you know
we thought we were being tough on them
but they'd already been through Allen
bucks
yeah just seeing the way that they
transform themselves and they absolutely
no handouts that have been given on this
program we made a bloody tough if
anything we made it tougher than we
normally would because we're at
reputational risk in our own minds of
employing women now I'm putting them out
there so we thought were you know you
know we're really gonna test them and
once we saw the potential capabilities
the toughness the resilience we became
our job to train yeah when you got the
first group of women and began the
training did you think like you know
this could go sideways like or did you
think like this is gonna work right from
the outset not from a halfway through
day one we knew we had a very special
somehow very different you can just see
you know you learn the most about
someone when they don't think they're
being watched and some of the stuff were
putting these women through and seeing
how they work together and just cracked
on with their you know a minimal fuss
and getting the job done and and you
know it was a pretty arduous and
dangerous environment at the time so how
many women are part of it now so we got
47 staff that are employed around 40 of
those are women and we got seven guys
that are working on building roads and
doing construction out in the bush and
we got James so James was the Skinner
for the hunting operation that used to
be there and so when someone would come
in and shoot an animal which doesn't
happen anymore we've bought we've bought
the company well that the area out
working with the the other stakeholders
there so we bought out the options to to
hunt there ever again I'm putting in
different models in but James who was
left over there he's now been trained as
a vegan
if so he used to skin an almost he's no
skinning potatoes and carrots at all
these women are eating vegan right yeah
the whole program is vegan and we took
that stance by making the program vegan
not necessarily making the women vegan
but giving them the opportunity and the
understanding of why we think
conservation should be leading the pack
in terms of driving a legal mess egde
around the world of people that had sign
up for conservation because they love
the environment or animals or a
combination of the two and what better
way to protect and also not to just to
come in your mouth yeah I saw that 60
minutes piece that just came out
recently right in Australia yeah Ayaka
shingu and it's emotional I mean to see
these women coming from the
circumstances that they were in to this
incredible place of empowerment and then
to be recognized and when they go back
to their communities or they go to
schools like everybody knows who they
are like it's it's a it's a big thing
yeah this this this unintended social
engineering that's going on there in
these communities where women were once
you know once a outcasts but you know
treated pretty very poorly and you know
they weren't necessarily victims of
circumstance they're largely victims of
men and to see now the the way that they
carry themselves and the respect they
have in the local community the way
they've been able to break down the
barrier between conservation and
community and build relationships and
conversations instead of conflict it's a
testament to I think what is it natural
quality that these women possess what
did the male villagers think of it so
when these women were coming for
selection they were told to to go back
home to essentially piss off back back
to the home and carry out their job
there as you know domestic workers and
you know they still they stuck their
head down and they turned up and they
went through the training and the ones
that made it through are now just
fantastic ambassadors in in the local
communities you know Abigail yeah you
know young lady she's um she's 19
finished school about a year and
half ago she goes back to a local school
now she's mobbed like a rock star by
every every young girl in that in that
school and you know she creates hope for
them and that's that's special to see
you know in a community where you know
women get pushed constantly right to the
back of the line right and what is the
effectiveness of the unit in terms of
combating poaching so when we first got
in there we would see animals as a
wildlife as little as once a week we're
now seeing animals coming in on it on
every patrol that we were going out the
women have made 76 RS which is sort of
unprecedented unprecedented success
throughout that area the distance
between where they operate from and
where they're making those arrests is
getting further and further apart so the
information they're getting is driving
them into the Syndicates and mid levels
of the Syndicates and breaking those
open information that they got last year
implicated former first lady Grace
Mugabe in ivory trafficking that led the
Zimbabwean government has set up a task
force so here you've got the most
oppressed demographic under the Mugabe
regime for 37 years being women in rural
communities now responsible for
triggering an investigation into one of
the most powerful women on the continent
Wow
so Mugabe is out now has that changed
anything politically well president
Mullingar war has taken over and you
know we hoping that more investment and
more visitors to Zimbabwe we'll see you
know it's actually a very safe and
beautiful country and Monica Aguas
daughter Tory Rho is one of the ranges
that works with this program yeah and
then it wasn't didn't magar B's wife get
busted for poaching yeah yeah yeah so
that's um you know and I mean Maga these
kids would be on Instagram tipping
champagne over their Rolex watches and
just carrying on like brats in general
and and he you've got the daughter of
the current president he's a you know
she spends time out there on the front
lawns patrolling to protect the natural
heritage and that's a huge change
do these syndicates operate with
relative impunity
I mean what is the you know how
effective is that govern is the
government complicit at all like what is
that what is the level of corruption
that allow these crime organizations to
flourish yeah I don't think a corruption
is isolated it is in barber and I
suppose any any different government
department is gonna have good people in
there and you're in a bad people and I
don't things in barber is any different
to the other countries over there you
know it it's always tough for
governments to look favorably upon
conservation particularly in the current
climate because conservation is becoming
increasingly militarized and it's
becoming increasingly militarized
because people are becoming increasingly
desperate and so we put our big offenses
and more guns and we are in war with the
local population on a continent that's
gonna have two billion people on it by
2040 now when a government is seen to
favor those actions they're viewed by
the people their voters as favoring the
lives of animals over people and that is
that that pushes the priority of
conservation further down that down the
list now with these women forming that
Ridge into these communities where we
did we're not having a war with the
local population we're having a
relationship with them it actually
brings conservation into a much more
favorable light for the government
mm-hmm and as somebody with with boots
on the ground over there what is the
real relationship between conservation
and trophy hunting because there's this
argument among hunters that you know by
participating in this structure that
exists over there that that is actually
contributing to the promotion of
conservation because of how they use the
funds okay I I don't I mean I used to
hunt you know to a chapter in my life
that I will be having to take to the
grave that's that's me what I dislike
more than hunting is the fact that we as
a global community have accepted it is
the only economic model to look after so
many areas and relied on it on it and
and you know this unethical model where
people pay to come and shoot something
so they can hang it on their
all has been the only way we've been
able to come up with those funds and for
us as and all those saying before we
wanted to look at it as it as an
equation to be solved and you know we're
hunting has put money into certain areas
to fund the protection of those areas
that that funding is drawing up and we
do need alter alternative models yeah I
would imagine you know social media has
played a part in making it less and less
popular for people to embark on those
trophy hunts you know with Cecil and the
like you know it's it's got to be a
dying thing is it
it definitely uses them in hunting is an
endangered species itself and one which
i think is going to be increasingly
reserved for the the uber-rich you've
got reduced wildlife populations from
poaching and in some cases hunting
trophy hunting and there is a
distinction between the two poaching is
is illegal and sanctioned trophy hunting
is legal and then the third the the you
know we've got tougher policies and laws
surrounding the export of trophies such
as ivory from countries like Zimbabwe to
places like America so it makes it
harder for the trophy hunter to bring
their trophy back and those sanctions
are normally imposed by entities such as
the US Fish and Wildlife Service when
they they assess a country's
conservation efforts and they try to
make different adjustments to help
conservation on the ground and the third
reason is exactly what you said social
media generation of people that are
grown up being able to see exactly what
hunting is at the click of a click of a
finger and make the decision that they
don't want to get on a plane to fly
across the world so they can shoot
something in the face anymore what is
the biggest obstacle to winning this war
on poaching look I think we definitely
need a shift in the balance of how we
look at protection of the natural world
and now our our future as a species is
directly intertwined with our
willingness to preserve biodiversity and
if we don't wake up and actually get
behind this environmental move whether
it's doing something about climate
change a small change a big
whatever whatever it is in your own home
with your own children if we don't do
something then we are the endangered
species this rock is being spinning
through three space for 5.3 billion
years doing its thing and it survived
much worse than mankind and unless we
can seriously get together and and get
behind this environmental movement and
shift things like this I mean this
crappy proportion of funding that we
have in the not-for-profit world from 5%
I'm a 5% seriously got 5% to look after
the natural world the the the world that
we'll have to live in and inhabit and
all these other animals have to live
here so if we can't seriously get that
right then we're [ __ ]
do you think you're pessimistic or
optimistic
I'm definitely optimistic mate you know
and I've had my I had my pessimist a
couple of years and you know the good
thing about crisis is it's like me in
South America man you can either [ __ ]
you can either get [ __ ] back out the
other side man and get up and dust
yourself off and and you know learn from
the lessons evolved or you can sit there
and be [ __ ] grumpy about it right but
uh you know what man is that there's a
there's a bunch of people that are doing
some really cool things and some
inspiring things you know it's a look if
you were to go back ten years and look
forward to today and look at all the
talk that's going on around protecting
the environment and and policy changes I
mean yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] things
going on out there but you know what
we're we're aware of them and when we're
aware we can start to make changes and I
don't think that you know there hasn't
been a point in history where people
have been so excited about trying to do
good things for the environment we just
need more and more momentum yeah it's
interesting how we as a culture are more
empathetic or we can wrap our heads
around getting here you want some more
water compassionate about these
incredible animals like rhinos and
elephants and the like but right under
our noses
is this you know massive industrial
complex known as factory farming and we
just haven't find it in ourselves to
extend that same sense of empathy or
concern to you know cattle and chick
and fish and these other animals that
you know we consume voraciously yeah
this I mean that's at speciesism which
is the same as sexism or racism
allocation of different values and
rights to different species and animals
depending on how convenient that they
are to us and this is you know I was a
victim of my own [ __ ] when I walked
around the bush for four years refusing
to acknowledge that a cow has the same
capacity to suffer as a runner and the
only difference we create between their
two abilities to suffer is the
difference we create in our own minds
and you know I was a master of coming up
with all these excuses as to why we you
know other animals didn't need the same
level of appreciation as what the ones
were that I was protecting cows aren't
going extinct or you know they've been
bred for us to eat you know I do so much
good work in conservation that I've
earned the right to be able to come home
and eat these animals and it's [ __ ]
and eventually here I suppose if you're
open enough to acknowledging the truth
it gets too much for you and that's a
good thing mm-hmm yeah it is interesting
you weren't you weren't vegan from the
outset you were kind of well into this
work before you know me nuts which for
yourself I mean I come from a background
of hunting not caring for the
environment and not giving a [ __ ] about
animals and I'm not proud of that but
you know what it's a it's a good start
point to have a conversation with pretty
much anyone yeah in the world because
you know some people have born close to
perfect I was you know quite the
opposite and it's it's being able to
change and being able to identify where
the mistakes are and use those as the
lessons and you know I can sit down with
Arthur from Texas I can sit down with
them with the guy that likes to eat his
steak because they used to be me yeah
you know well not only that I mean
you're not you know a dreadlocked hippie
you know it's like you walk in and you
cut this very masculine frame and you
have your background that you have and I
think that that you know with that gives
you some gravitas to walk into a room
and be taken seriously on issues that
perhaps would be dismissed if somebody
who
different than you was trying to
communicate them yeah what I mean
I mean it's back to that like issue
about masculinity all different shapes
and sizes you know and I'll still say
that the the the best decision I've ever
made in my life either for everything
I've done places or been the best
decision I've ever made is to go vegan
and to acknowledge that and you know
what you don't even have to get out of
bed before you're doing something good
for the environment good for animals and
it's a really liberating feeling to know
that because I mean we've I mean I don't
think there's anybody out there
listening to that it doesn't have some
sort of connection with animals whether
it's a dog or a cat or you go out to a
farm you've been to Africa or whatever
it might be you can't look in the eyes
of an animal and deny that animal
doesn't want the same thing as us it
wants safety and once shelter wants to
live without suffering it wants to live
with that have to line up and get and
walk into a slaughterhouse just like any
other person would and I think we're
gonna look back we're gonna look back at
some stage and be ashamed of what we've
done as a species and you know it's
[ __ ] good to be on the right side of
history rich what do you think is the
biggest stumbling block for for most
people and wrapping their heads around
going vegan honestly acknowledging the
truth because you flash up the you know
the the the story or the video of where
meat actually comes from people like
pushing I turn it off what I want to see
it don't want to see it people don't
want to know people don't want to
acknowledge the truth and know it they
just don't want to listen to it and you
know if you really let your own guard
down internally let your guard down and
analyze yourself and and just do you
really want to be a person that pays
somebody else to do something to animals
you're not willing to do yourself and
you know I think if we just take the
time to reflect and have a think about
what's on our plate and where did that
come from
and what did it go through to get there
you know anyone with any conscience we
wouldn't want that happening to their
own child and my mother their father
their brother their sister so why would
you want it happening to something else
yeah not only something else honey that
just doesn't have the ability
to defend itself yeah certainly this
movement is on the rise more and more
people are adopting this lifestyle but
there's still a long way to go for full
mainstream adaptation to it I think
there's a long way to go but you know
we're a species that responds well to
crisis and I think you know as a we've
been Dara and graves with our teeth as a
civilization and I think we're starting
to understand that when we look at
global warming and we look at the effect
that the meat industry is having on our
planet and on our health we not [ __ ]
stupid we know what we're doing we just
don't acknowledge it and I think as we
get further and further into the corner
people are starting to wake up and it's
cool it's it's actually exciting my it
is you know I come here to LA I go to
New York wherever and I'm talking vegan
restaurants and all these red dots pop
up and you walk in you can't get a
bloody seat anyway you know and it's
it's a good thing man good things are
happening by good people and it's
catching on yeah and and young people
are are really on board with this and in
a way that my generation isn't which is
exciting as you know what and funny you
should mention that because so many
people say oh you know we've got to get
the children involved that's where the
future is that's [ __ ] everybody it's
never too late to change ok we can't
rely on the children to fix this the
next generation it's everyone's
responsibility and everyone's
responsibility now
just because we've done something for 50
60 70 years that may not have been right
it doesn't matter too late to change and
you know it's it's a very liberating
thing when you get with the program how
old is your son now I've got a five year
old son and got a young daughter as well
my daughter - I don't know so what is
the world that you would like to see for
them you know I'd like them to be able
to grow up in in a world where animals
are not treated as commodities where
animals are given the right to live out
their lives as as as we would like to
live out ours and that is you know the
flow-on effects when we have that
compassion towards animals and protect
the environment is is I think a much
happier world
first of all to live in yeah it's
amazing work that you're doing I would
presume that you're here in the States
trying to raise funds and awareness
right so if people are listening to this
and they want to learn more they want to
get involved they want to contribute or
donate how do they do that yeah thanks
thanks for asking that rich mate yeah
you know I'm going to come over here
three times a year and do a bunch of
lectures around the country fundraisers
this trip is a short one two weeks on
the ground and if anybody wants to know
more information they can go to WWII a
PFG org or type in anti-poaching into
google that will come up the
International anti-poaching foundation
yeah it's it's no donation is too small
or too big I'll throw that one in but uh
yeah we really appreciate all the people
around the world that make the work that
we do on the ground possible and what do
you most need the funds for like how
would you deploy those funds if you
could meet all of your budgetary dreams
so at the moment we are scaling up the
UH cachinga program as we're about what
what we do is we we buy the long-term
leases in collaboration with the local
community of these hunting areas and
we're looking to purchase the the place
next door now and that's going to cost
us just over three hundred thousand US
dollars a year to run and that means
that we'll there will be a twenty five
year lease on that area so for 25 years
and we'll renew it again after that
that'll be 50 years that hunting will
not take place on there and animals can
just do what animals to go about go
about their lives we've got a 2025
vision of having 20 areas that have been
reclaimed from trophy hunting it'll take
a thousand women to manage and protect
and putting six point seven million
dollars a year into the local
communities it seems like it's super
scalable right to take the the training
techniques that you have and deploy them
to groups of women in different
communities you know across Africa and
beyond and also it seems like a system
that would work well for other types of
endeavors beyond animal protection might
if funny you should mention so well
we go into an area a conservation area
in a small country in southern Africa
and able to switch the dynamics in the
local community where law enforcement is
involved and in a much more positive way
a much more cost-effective way and we
don't need helicopters and more guns and
bigger fences we have in those
conversations but if we can do this in a
conservation setting imagine what we can
do but you're outside of conservation
beyond concentration beyond Zimbabwe I
think it's really exciting to see what
this program is gonna go yeah and what
are the differences country to country
you know when you go to the neighboring
countries outside of Zimbabwe as the the
legal landscape change is poaching
different they're 56 countries on the
continent every one is different so I'm
in better ways some and worse look every
current we are operating now in Kenya
Mozambique South Africa and Zimbabwe we
just did a trial leadership training
program in Uganda last week so we're
constantly having a deal and in
different climates different settings
different languages cultures and
political structures so we we actually
have a matrix where we assess what we're
going to do and where we're going to do
it and why and political will is a very
high scoring metric in in that
calculator if you want to call it that
and you know did it's a very powerful
thing when you have political will
behind you and in favor of conservation
and it's a huge hurdle when you don't
yeah what's the biggest obstacle or
hurdle that you're facing like short
term right now that you're trying to
overcome so coming funding is always a
it's always a tough struggle where an
organization that has some of the best
people in the industry at ground level
running the programs and trailblazing in
conservation and then you know we've
been less successful in in hiring the
fundraisers or or getting our head
around it ourselves and you know it's
just it's been a struggle on this this
side of the pond in terms of getting
funding and you know we have a really
simple scalable model that is working in
a way that is more effective than any
other operation I've been involved with
before
pioneering it's a viable economic
alternative for trophy hunting we've
shifted the strategy of conservation to
put female empowerment at the top is the
most effective single dollar to be spent
in community development and
conservation became the byproduct we are
lifting up communities putting a
majority of conservation funding into
Community Development and you know on
top of all that the program is is a is a
launchpad using some of the most
powerful ambassadors we have in these
societies driving a plant-based vegan
message at grassroots brew rural level
and you know no big change in history
ever started from the top down it always
comes from the grassroots ice always
alright well let's close this down
parting words for somebody who's
listening to this who perhaps is coming
into this awareness for the first time
had no idea these things are going on in
Africa is new to the vegan message is
interested in taking that first step
getting involved as an activist or just
in terms of their own personal consumer
choices every single day what do you
what can you leave for that person it
look I mean we can't change the world by
ourselves we can do it together and that
starts with with changing the things in
our world and changing them for the
better we can't protect any every animal
but we can protect the ones that are in
our lives and I think it just if we just
open up to ourselves and acknowledge the
truth of where our food comes from and
and the suffering that is happening to
animals out there if we just acknowledge
that as individuals I think the world
would be a much better place hopefully
one day I'll be out of bloody work you
know because because animals aren't
being threatened animals aren't being
treated as commodities they've been
treated as people and people that
deserve our protection I think that's
everyone's responsibility we have to we
have to train men and women up to
certain levels with various skills and
arm them and send them out into the bush
risking their life every day to protect
animals the simple way to protect them
isn't
- stick em in your mouth you know and we
can all do that that's the power that we
all have and it's a it's a powerful
thing powerful indeed super
inspirational thank you for everything
that you do you're doing incredible work
so for everybody that's listening please
explore Damien's world and what he's
doing get involved contribute donate if
you haven't already please watch his TED
talk also the 60 minutes piece on the on
the hawkish Ginga I'll link those up in
the show notes so you can learn more and
come back and talk to me again my friend
rich thanks very much man thanks for
what you do and the message the drive
and everyone out there - for those
sitting on the fence you know just keep
keep reading keep educating yourself
because once the shadows come up they
never go down again peace plants
[Music]
you